Tom let me compliment you for the third
time this morning well done with you and
Harold last night it was great listen so
thanks for joining us oh thanks for
having me I think while we iron through
the technology problems there the
Dodgers and national change more time
that was a long seventh inning can you
remember an inning that was that long
had anywhere near those kind of pitching
changes in the postseason no it's kind
of like the usual suspects I'm gonna
have to go back and watch this uh you
know it's funny last year we had the
first round texas toronto and that game
five was unbelievably emotional and
dramatic you know that was the Batista
bat flip the fans are throwing things on
the field same inning seventh inning I
think this one was even crazy i think it
was longer when did you realize that
Kershaw was going to be a possibility
what's honey before the game Dave
Roberts said that's not a possibility
come on guys um and I was watching him
the dugout and he was the dugout for
most of the game so I assume he was not
going to be available you know being the
dugout just watching game anybody who's
available they're usually down the
bullpen pretty early what I saw him
walks him to check out out to the
bullpen late in game uses an eighth or
ninth inning I guess the eighth inning I
just said wow it was just an incredible
moment where he's walking across the
outfield by himself with this place on
this time and you're like okay sheriff's
riding into town right now what if he
didn't pitch will I don't think it
bothered him at all I don't think he's
obviously not afraid of that you know I
thought Dan going into the game the
biggest thing for me was there was going
to be a spot where the Nationals would
have Daniel Murphy at the plate and who
did Dave Roberts trust to get through
Daniel Murphy late in the game because I
thought in a five-game series Luis
Avilan and grant Dayton the two lefties
he'd already seen both those guys fight
at murphs just too smart the more he
sees somebody you know the mystery is
gone facing him it never occurred to me
that Kershaw would be the guy and
Roberts had set up so that if Murphy
spot came up there was nobody trusted
more than Clayton Kershaw so I give him
credit it's a good question you asked
what happened if you fail
and it would have blown up both on the
manager and on curse um but man I listen
go back to the game he pitched two days
before where he took the ball on short
rest you know Max Scherzer was starting
game five because he could not start on
short rest and they had to give up you
know Joe Ross it really hasn't pitched a
lot coming off the DL and you know
shorter just said listen I've never done
it before I think it would have an
effect on me the next time I go out
there if we advance and that typical of
the modern pitcher well Clayton Kershaw
is not typical of the modern pitcher so
you work two days after throwing 110
pitches over six and two-thirds and then
come in and get the final two outs
before I look ahead to the NLCS the
Nationals you get the feeling a couple
of years ago it was hey this is just the
start of something big and winning a
division here we are with the one and
done again if you're a nationals fan how
do you tell them to have hope oh man you
got to pit your stomach today they've
got some true demon damn you know gone
back to 2012 when you had you know the
Strasbourg shut down and then the
cardinals coming back on drew storm the
ninth-inning 2014 you had Matt Williams
taken out Jordan Zimmermann when he had
the game under control against the giant
bruise about one and now this actually
go back the you know game four in this
game you have it was a one nothing lead
a slim lead but you still had a one
nothing lead with Max Scherzer just
completely dealing going to the seventh
inning and this one gets away too uh
yeah this is a punch in the gut for
Washington that franchise is really
stuck in neutral I thought it was very
important for them to get through the
first round for the psyche to franchise
especially their fans and that's this a
big hit for them I'm for Dusty Baker I
mean I gotta feel sorry for the guy nine
straight times me playing a game that
would get him to the next around nine
straight classes and Jayson Werth
getting thrown out at home I mean did
you want to you want to push that
situation but not to that degree did
they send him or did he go on his own no
they said I'm bad and it was a terrible
call listen I get the whole idea with
two outs you wanna be super aggressive
my issue is is Bob Henly third-base
coach because you watch the replay as a
third-base coach you have to get far
down the line
to home plate so you can let the play
develop and Andrew Tolleson leftfielder
made a great play because he got to the
ball before it got to the wall so once
you see him cut the ball off you have to
hold work but Henley actually was toward
the left field side of third base and
didn't give the plate time to play out
so he's sending worth right as holes is
cutting the ball off if you go back to
you see Chase Headley Chase Utley's
actually putting his hands up to tell
Corey Seager hold the cut he's not going
he couldn't believe it himself that he
was drawing it could have rolled the
ball home and got him out at home that's
that call the Dodgers beat the Cubs if I
could Clayton Kershaw fits four times
listen I gotta win every game he pitches
and that we game 3 i'm assuming game 7
if it gets that far I don't think
they'll bring them back short again but
who knows you Superman right now I have
a hard time seeing the Dodgers Dodgers
winning four times now listen Dave
Roberts loves managing these crazy
unconventional games he's got relief
pitchers will go in anytime anywhere
he's got that Thun advantage but Cubs
deeper refresher I mean then this is how
magical the Cubs season has been that
this is exactly what teams hope for when
you get to the next round that your
opponent in the first round basically
gets exhausted new by playing a
knock-down drag-out series and they come
in at less than full straight that's
exactly what just happened to the
Dodgers what should we keep an eye on
with Toronto and Cleveland which starts
tonight a bullpen usage again with terry
francona you know he's got that piece
and Andrew Miller talked about using
guys at any time shut down relief
pitcher you can't run on him he doesn't
walk anybody the game comes to a halt
when he comes in the game he's the
neutralizer so firing that phone I like
Cleveland in this series I think they
have the better bullpen these games for
the most part across all these theories
have been bull pen game and i love the
way Terry Francona uses his guys safe
travels tell the boys we settle oh thank
you Tom you got that like you max Tom
Verducci with Harold Reynolds Kenny
Albert it was it was a great listen last
night they just point out small thing
that's what's fun certainly about
postseason baseball the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience